Tụi xa lâu sẽ giá vào xa này 1 chiến thằng sau,
tại hiện chương một khối lượng lớn đất đá từ tà lý dương đổ xu mắt đường.
Vui lấp một phần trước sẽ ổ tổ con nhận hiệu hình đại đáng lưu thông qua khu bực.
Thang huy zân địa phương thời điểm xa giá xa lâu trên xe của bán người,
rất mai không về thiệt hải bình người.
Hẹn tình đường từ phương tân phòng li sẽ an nấm tâm và các xả vùng thấp của hệ xin hồ của bị a tắc hòn tòn.
Được lượng chương đăng địa phương đăng vi động mấy móc, phương tiét,
hình chương xan gạm đất đá, các phục sự cố nhằm sớm thông tuyến,
cho nghĩ dầu qua nhiều nơi trên địa bán tình lại trâu của ý nhận lượng mơ lớn,
có nơi trên chỉ mới mấy mẹ,
mù hình đồ ởm đất trò thấy một số khu bực đả gần bảo qua,
phật đặt trạm thải bảo qua,
làm ra tăng huy cơ xảy ra lúc quét, xa lợ đất và sự lốn.
Ngành chức năng quyền càng huy zân thường xuyên thật gió các bán tin cạnh báo,
hàn trời dí chuyển qua khu bực có huy cơ xa lợ,
tự nối không đi bảo các niềm đá,
số hiện nất đất, sự lốn,
phật nước trảy siet để đảm bảo ăn quan trong thời gian mửi lúc tiếp dẫn.